pour moi l'évidence n'existe pas et
pourtant être féministe faire du
bénévolat voté lors de chaque élection
ne pas boire d'alcool parler plusieurs
langues jouer de plusieurs instruments
ça me paraît évident pourquoi ce qui est
évident pour moi ne l'est pas pour vous
et s'il ya autant d'évidence que
d'individus alors comment se comprendre
et comment se respecter pour moi
l'évidence n'existe pas car en tant que
jeune femme métisse croyante
on m'a souvent sollicité pour répondre à
de grandes questions sur la société sur
les relations humaines ou encore sur
l'actualité politique en pensant que
j'aurai forcément une réponse je vous
donne quelques exemples dix mois il ya
beaucoup de couples mixtes dans ton
entourage
quel est le secret pour qu'il soit
encore ensemble aujourd'hui où tu dis
que tu es féministe mais comment tu peux
être féministe site est croyante
si j'ai toujours apprécié jouer le rôle
de porte parole d'un groupe
là ça faisait beaucoup de monde à
représenter les couples mixtes les
croyantes les féministes et bien souvent
je ne savais pas quoi répondre à ces
questions puisque à mes yeux
elles n'ont rien d'évident alors ce que
j'ai essayé de faire plusieurs fois
c'est de reformuler la question elle ça
pouvait donner quelque chose de
loufoques comme si j'ai bien compris tu
me demande pourquoi je suis moi et
comment je peux l'être c'est ça en
grandissant je me suis dit que si mon
entourage multiculturel et
multiconfessionnel qui vit en fait
attisées autant de regards et de
curiosité c'est que ça n'était pas
évident pour tout le monde et les gens
qui me posait ses questions espérait
ainsi que je puisse justifier ce qui
pour eux n'étaient ni compréhensible ni
évident alors vous me direz comment
connaître nos évidences et celle des
autres et surtout à partir de cela
comment mieux vivre ensemble
si nous naissons toutes et tous libres
et égaux en dignité et en droits dans
les faits les inégalités persistent et
c'est ce qui m'a donné envie de
m'engager dans le bénévolat
j'avais 16 ans je n'avais pas de projet
précis mais je souhaitais aller vers les
autres et pour que cette rencontre ait
du sens il fallait qu'elle ne repose pas
sur un contrat matériel je souhaitais me
rendre disponible et cela gratuitement
j'étais alors en tunisie et je possédais
un super appareil photo un de ses
appareils photos qui rendra toujours
votre moment magique
du moins c'est ce que la publicité
annoncée j'ai rejoint une amie qui est
membre de l'association des étudiants de
médecine de son université et qui
accompagné chaque semaine des enfants
handicapés lors d'une sortie équestre
j'allais donc suivi lors d'une de leur
sortie et j'ai tâché d'être la
photographe du jour est de capturer les
instants de complicité entre les enfants
et les bénévoles et le résultat a été
déterminant tout d'abord les enfants et
les bénévoles ont été ravis d'obtenir de
superbes portraits la publicité ne monte
donc pas complètement et cette
expérience a été très positive pour moi
pourtant j'ai mis du temps avant de la
nommer comme tel ma première expérience
en tant que bénévole j'ai mis du temps
car pour moi prendre des photos ça
n'avait rien d'héroïque je n'avais pas à
sauver deux vies
je n'avais pas lutter pour une cause
j'étais allé vers les autres j'avais
rejoint le monde de la solidarité le
temps d'un après-midi monde dont je ne
me suis pas vraiment éloigné finalement
alors quoi de mieux que la l'engagement
bénévole pour découvrir ce qui est
important pour les autres mais aussi
pour nous car c'est bien là l'enjeu
essayer de se connaître soi même
et c'est finalement cette expérience qui
m'a ouvert la voie vers ce qu'il ya de
plus important pour moi aujourd'hui la
notion d'engagement
l'engagement dans un groupe
l'engagement pour une cause l'engagement
pour ce qui a du sens pour moi et le
bénévolat était la meilleure façon de
s'engager
après si ce que je fais gratuitement tu
ne ferais que si tu es payé
est ce que cela fait de toi quelqu'un de
moins engagé la réalité est que nous
avons tous des projets de vie différent
et des combats à mener
l'important est de se lancer dawes et de
tenter d'essayer de s'engager pour
trouver ce qui a véritablement du sens
pour nous de connaître nos évidences et
d'en découvrir d'autres
j'aimerais désormais vous emmener en
irlande où d'autres rencontres m'ont
éclairé sur nos évidences nos acquis et
les manières de nous engager
là bas j'ai rejoint un collectif
féministe j'ai découvert des
revendications qui ne m'avaient pas
suivi dans ma vie quotidienne tels que
la lutte pour le droit à l'avortement
j'ai surtout rencontré des femmes
inspirantes solidaire et qui proposait
un modèle de dialogue que je trouve
juste et inclusive puisque les membres
de ce collectif faisait preuve d'une
grande bienveillance à l'égard des
luttes que chacun chacune soit été
portée
j'ai eu la chance d'échanger avec la
leader de ce collectif qui m'a expliqué
que l'organisation de l'équipe ne devait
pas être sous-estimée par rapport à la
cause qui réunissait tous les membres je
me souviens une fois lui avoir demandé
mais comment vous faites avec autant
d'idées et de revendications différentes
elle m'a et elle m'a répondu tu ne
changera pas le monde avec des idées les
gens ont tous des idées
et c'est très bien tu changeras le monde
avec des actrices et des acteurs
porteurs du changement et c'est là que
j'ai compris que finalement tout cette
histoire d'engagement ne repose que sur
de l'humain des individus qu'il faut
savoir gérer avec leur évidence
cependant tout n'est pas rose dans le
monde de la solidarité
car si bien souvent les membres du
groupe se rejoignent sur la cause à
défendre l'égalité par exemple les
priorités et les moyens d'action à
mettre en oeuvre pour y parvenir peuvent
varier d'une personne à une autre
et c'est là qu'entre en jeu le choc des
évidences et on peut obtenir un schéma
avec d'un côté les radicaux
de l'autre les modérés les radicaux pour
lesquels il faudra être visible dès
aujourd'hui et éventuellement avoir
recours à la violence si nécessaire de
l'autre côté les modérés eux ont cherché
à s'unir avec d'autres groupes qui nous
ressemble afin d'être plus forts
ensemble mais c'est aussi d'un côté les
pragmatiques et de l'autre les
inspirational les pragmatiques pour
lesquels il faudra se concentrer sur
comment agir et avoir un impact dès
aujourd'hui les inspirational qui eux
auront besoin d'un objectif d'une
mission qui s'inscrit dans le long terme
et répond à la question pourquoi sommes
nous réunit alors avec cette diversité
d'évidence il faut savoir jongler et
essayer d'établir une stratégie commune
puisque nous nous inscrivons tous dans
une seule et même réalité
enfin si le bénévolat peut être une
solution pour aller vers les autres
les évidences culturelles peuvent
parfois constitué d
fille qu'il faut essayer de relever et
pour distinguer ces évidences culturel
il n'y a pas besoin d'aller très long il
n'y a pas besoin de métissage ou encore
de choc des générations
il y a juste besoin de deux individus
confrontés à une seule et même réalité
en grandissant on a tous expérimenté ça
ce qui est évident pour notre entourage
devient énigmatique voire parfois
incompréhensibles je pense par exemple
aux valeurs aux goûts aux logiques
diverses qui viennent prouver que
l'évidence unique n'existe pas et pour
comprendre les étiquettes que l'on
distribue volontiers autour de nous quoi
de mieux que d'essayer d'analyser ce qui
se passe chez nous sous notre toit
engager le dialogue avec ce dont nous
sommes proches peut parfois s'avérer
plus complexe que d'aller à la rencontre
de parfaits inconnus
l'idée donc d'aller vers nos exotiques
semblables
l'expression vient d'une grande
voyageuse qui s'est rendu de paris à
pékin à pied et que je suis allé écouter
récemment et en l'entendant je me suis
souvenu d'une sacrée expérience que j'ai
vécue comme l'un des plus gros choc les
évidences de ma vie avec deux individus
dont je suis pourtant très proches mes
parents voici donc l'histoire d'un
rendez vous raté pour vous la raconter
j'aimerais que vous mettiez à ma place
et que vous essayez de répondre à cette
question
que fait-on lorsque une personne que
l'on ne peut pas joindre nous attend
dans un aéroport et que l'on se trouve
dans un autre j'ai bien précisé que l'on
ne peut pas contacter la personne et
c'est donc
là qu'entre en jeu le superbe choc des
évidences j'ai vécu cette situation et
pour m'en sortir j'ai décidé de faire
appel à une personne médiatrice ma mère
qui m'a conseillé de me rendre dans
l'aéroport de rendez vous car c'est bien
là que j'étais attendu faire appel à une
personne médiatrice a été une très
mauvaise idée car au lieu de suivre mon
fils d'évidence je me suis perdu dans
une situation qui pour moi n'avait aucun
sens mais qui pour d'autres
répondez à une certaine logique et donc
forcément c'est cette logique il fallait
que je le fasse
la personne qui devait venir me chercher
et en mon père j'étais persuadé qu'une
fois arrivés dont l'aéroport de rendez
vous il aurait bien vu que mon vol
n'était pas annoncée et que je m'étais
trompé
j'avais très peu de temps pour prendre
ma décision et comme c'était d'un côté
mon père de l'autre ma mère il n'y avait
pas un avis plus légitime que l'autre
donc naturellement j'ai suivi l'avis de
la seule personne avec qui j'étais en
communication alors qu'est ce que ça a
donné concrètement j'ai fini par
retrouver mon père après quelques heures
moi essayant de me rendre dans
l'aéroport de rendez-vous lui essayant
de se rendre dans l'aéroport où j'étais
véritablement arrivée nous nous sommes
retrouvés à mi chemin entre les deux
aéroports
et là au moment où je monte enfin dans
la voiture de mon père pour rentrer à la
maison
j'ai le droit à deux questions
vous imaginez l'ambiance tendue
premièrement pourquoi tu ne m'as pas
attendu puis
pourquoi tu n'es pas rentrer à la maison
par ses propres moyens
bonne question puisque c'était ce qui
lui semblait évident à faire et à moi
aussi
deux aéroports
la mère le père l'art de suivre deux
fils d'évidence dans les temps de crise
c'est souvent évidence contre évidence
et il faut éviter de tomber dans le
piège
moi je suis tombé dedans car si j'ai
réussi il analyse je n'ai pas osé la
suivre jusqu'au bout
quiproquos manque de communication
certainement mais ce qui ressort le plus
dans cette histoire c'est bien que nos
évidences peuvent engendrer des tensions
voire des conflits qu'il faut bien
essayer de résoudre et le défi est de
taille lorsqu'il s'attaque à nos
évidences personnel à les expériences de
vie avec nos proches sont plus
fascinantes qu'on ne le croit alors
allez-y foncez
essayez dès maintenant de décrypter avec
quel regard vos proches voient la
réalité ça vous évitera bien des
conflits si à plusieurs reprises je me
suis senti obligé fort c'est d'essayer
de comprendre ce qui m'entoure de cerner
leur logique pour ne pas juste et juger
si j'y arrive
vous pouvez le faire connaissez vos
évidence questionner les pour ensuite
mieux appréhender celle des autres nous
sommes toujours plus habiles et
diplomates que nous pensons pouvoir
l'être au fait
j'ai oublié de vous dire quelque chose
quand j'étais plus jeune je souhaitais
devenir funambule au fond marcher sur un
fil pour se rendre d'un point a à un
point b rien plus difficile n'est-ce pas
cela demande beaucoup d'entraînement et
une certaine agilité
pourtant ce fils c'est aussi le moyen le
plus direct de se rendre au point b et
c'est possible
alors à la question qu'on m'a posée en
venant ici
quelle est ta vision d'avenir je
répondrai une société de funambule
voilà ma vision d'avenir une société où
l'on n'ose aller directement vers
l'autre parlé avec l'autre plutôt que à
la place de l'autre sous prétexte que
l'on imagine savoir comment l'autre
résonne une société où l'on essaie
d'aller vers l'autre pour mieux le
comprendre et mieux vivre ensemble dans
le respect ce n'est pas l'option la plus
simple mais cela permet d'éviter de
distribuer des étiquettes des catégories
et de se prêter des identités
meurtrières
osons donc remettre en question nos
évidences et nous vivrons mieux ensemble
en paix alors finalement tout ce que
j'ai dit c'était évident non
[Applaudissements]